Don't use that example and I think
clearly it's a challenge to complete the
whole a bicycle wheel around that happen
in the upper west side.
Then the,
I mean,
especially to the north,
you necessarily to work a lot to
complete the uh,
pedestrian and bicycle walk.
We buy the water side.
There are many,
many streets were protected bicycle way
needed because I'm,
some even seems to be,
I mean some were painted initially and
now they seem to be getting rid of them
like intense three days,
you know,
it's like getting a race.
The ones that was painted so clearly.
Clearly there is a space in New York,
which is the real issue is the parking
space for cars in the streets.
I mean
the United States constitution has as
many rights people in the United States
have a right to live without fear,
without crime.
They have a right to free education.
They have a right to,
to work,
to have many rights,
but they.
Parking is not a constitutional right,
eh?
I think it should be questioned more
seriously,
whether it's how to use this space,
which has now been taken by cars,
parking by the curb side is that small
minority of people who are taking up
these extremely valuable space in the
streets of New York to park and I think
in many streets do you call the red
guard rail parking and make some much
bigger side.
We'll just make some fantastic protected
bicycle ways in all directions.
Some regulations I think also have to be
enacted so that people can walk in with
bicycles into,
into the elevators and into the
hallways.
I saw that.
I mean,
if people can go with dogs or we shows
into a,
into a hallway or in a little later,
why not go with a bicycle,
but this New York,
I think Manhattan in particular is the
perfect city to,
for everybody to move by bicycle and
even in the,
in the winter is possible in most of the
winter with,
uh,
some,
coats
to go by bicycle level
everywhere.